est-ce que selon vous le rire est utile
lui estampes et jean-jacques de son
prénom dessinateur humoristique un brin
sarcastique
est ce que vous pensez vous que de
manger c'est utile ou que de marcher
marcher on se demande si tu t il
finalement de marché flambé dessinateur
de presse depuis les années 50 j'essaie
de faire de psa un drôle une rencontre
va changer sa vie tel de rené goscinny
en 1954
ensemble ils donnent naissance au petit
nicolas indémodable j'ai écrit les
comptes que sempé enregistrés ce qui
leur a valu le succès sachant qu mais
face au papier pourtant paix des idées
ne fusent pas si je savais comment fin
de ce1 en problème sera extrêmement
simple il décrit son processus comme
laborieux blanc est bien souvent à la
fin l'auteur reste un stade dissipée
quand je dessine quand je suis quelqu'un
qui sourit je souris mais quand je vais
lui laisser quelqu'un qui est effrayée
général frei et ses titres l église et
pour moi c'est très difficile de trouver
des expressions des personnages que je
voudrais communiquer le dessinateur
n'est pas fan de la télé mais ils jouent
le jeu un brin malicieux pince sans rire
difficile de cerner l'artiste en
interview tout comme au travers de ses
dessins on arrive bien à savoir envers
membres des sas si vous êtes optimiste
ou pessimiste politique dans la vie
nationale
tempérament optimiste parce qu'on
pourrait croire tout ça il faut quand
même apprendre le dessin humoristique
trop trop au sérieux non plus destiné
aussi à vous amuser dans ses livres et
longtemps dans la presse sempé à croquer
pour l'express le figaro télérama paris
match il est inclassable
quel que soit aujourd'hui ça m'a
toujours rendu complètement fou qu'on
puisse à assimiler le destin que je
faisais le dessin humoristique alors un
dessin humoristique c'est vraiment
l'expression rarement complet de la
liberté n'ont aucun rapport avec le
dessin humoristique n'a aucun rapport et
de dessin politique aucun rapport ni
avec le dessin satirique un autre
terrain de jeu s'offre à lui dans les
années 70 et 80
sempé destine pour le magazine new
yorker presque de quoi détourner les
yeux d'une presse française qu'ils
jugent trop frileuse mouvement des
dessins j'en fais mais je crois que dans
les journaux français s'intéressent pour
ça et c'est trés dans le fond ça les
gens ne prennent plus beaucoup de
risques maintenant et tout le monde a
trop peur
un dessin humoristique ne peut pas être
compris par tout le monde c'est
impossible
en 70 ans jean jacques sempé a dessiné
le monde qui l'entourent avec une poésie
et malice enfantine éternel insatisfait
il voit ses oeuvres mises aux enchères
peut-être de quoi lui faire oublier ses
anciennes certitudes à supporter les
quelque chose d'intéressant son médecin
c'est pas moi je suis absolument pas
[Musique]